[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
put a smile on that face with a lot of
news coming forward that we may be
getting a joker sequel at some point
this comes straight from the clown's
mouth with Joaquin Phoenix in a recent
interview with Pierre Travis stating
that he can't stop thinking about the
role and it's something that he's been
discussing with director Todd Phillips I
play the clip from the interview in just
a second but make sure you subscribe to
the channel to keep up to date with all
the news on the upcoming DC movies
anyway this is great news for fans of
the film as Phoenix's famously being
someone who never took part in sequels
but it seems like you may be interested
in going forward with Joker after this
let's play the clip but now obviously
like I can't stop thinking about it a
lot about what else we might be able to
do in general just working together but
also specifically is there something
else with Joker that that might be
interesting so it ended up being a jury
rule I don't it's it's nothing that that
I really wanted to do prior to work are
you saying that yes you don't do sequels
you know there's no to even say that
there's more to do I don't know that
there is there is but you're not
closed-minded about it
no and it's you know I think me Todd
would still be shooting now if we could
write because it seemed endless the
possibilities and where we could go with
the character you don't have any dream
to be in a scene with Batman no Ivan had
that around that debt ring we'll see it
could be coming because the Batman is
coming so who knows right it's up there
okay so there's quite a lot to impact
from all that and I definitely recommend
that you check out the full 25-minute
interview which are linked in the
description below
going off just this clip though it's
clear that Phoenix is obsessed
with the role and that he wishes to
explore some of the endless
possibilities with the character I as
I'm sure many would love to see a return
and there's so many hanging questions
over the film that I could happily watch
another two hours with all the flack
that shows him terrorizing Gotham the
character clearly can't be held by
Arkham as we saw in the film's finale
and with the tie-in to the Wayne family
murders there's definitely potential to
see the Clown Prince of Crime go up
against the Caped Crusader another
interesting aspect of this interview is
that the actor doesn't completely shut
down rumors of this being tied to the
upcoming Batman movie in the run-up to
the film it was publicized everywhere
that this would be a standalone film and
all of the rumors of it being tied to
the Batman was shut down pretty quickly
but the tide seems to be turning now you
may remember earlier in the year that in
an interview with variety Robert
Pattinson was asked to comment on the
possibility of meeting with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker on-screen and after
making a comment on it he asked to
retract it from the interview now this
instantly made headlines across the
internet and whilst we will never know
what was said in the interview the fact
that it had to be retracted hints that
things may be in development that the
public shouldn't be privy to in addition
to this there are also rumors that have
emerged this week from we got this
covered who stayed at the same source
that told them Viola Davis was returning
for Suicide Squad and that black atom
would be in Shazam 3 that Warner
Brothers are interested in doing a
sequel as of the 13th of October the
film has grossed over half a billion
dollars and it just makes sense
business-wise to have the character go
beyond his first film the studio may
even be putting the pieces in place to
eventually have the two come face to
face down the line similar to how Marvel
created standalone films before their
big crossover I would absolutely love to
see this and it did slightly put it down
on Joker whilst watching it thinking
that we may never see this performance
again
however this interview gives a lot of
hope and honestly I'll be absolutely
over the moon if it gets pushed into
development it just makes sense from a
business point of view and obviously the
plans will be behind it DC need as many
hits as they can get right now and what
better way to rebuild their reputation
with a sequel to their best film since
the Dog Night there is really no
downside to it and fingers crossed that
we get to see Return of the jakka
like to jock in Phoenix like jakka have
rode the video of sorry now obviously I
loved hear your thoughts on this
interview and if you think a sequel will
happen or not coming below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of who Joker's
true father is which would be linked at
the end we went over all of the evidence
did the digital DNA test and definitely
have the answers so make sure you check
that out if you want something else to
watch again I'll leave the link to the
Peter Travis interview in the
description and if you want to come
follow me on Twitter just here up at
definition why teen I've also just
started up my discord server which will
be linked below so head over to join the
community as it's the best way to keep
up to date with the channel also just
want to let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Joker sequel in the comments section
below
who will be chosen at random on October
the 15th and the blue row be shipped out
from Mentos forget surprise so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]